guten abend liebe mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger wir haben keine schluss
erklärung anzubieten im augenblick habe
ich zahlen sprechen eine deutliche
sprache eine überzeugende geschichte wir
werden das rennen gewinnen
schauen sie sich an das seit gestern
geschehen ist in 24 stunden
wir lagen hinten in georgia und liegen
jetzt vorne
wir werden den start gewinnen 24 stunden
vor 24 stunden lagen wir ihn in
pennsylvania und wir werden auch diesen
staat gewinnen und jetzt liegen wir vorn
wollen aber noch in arizona in nevada
gewinnen unsere führung hat sich in der
wade jetzt verdoppelt wir sind in der
spur
bei der auszählung und schauen sich die
landesweiten zahlen an wir werden mit
einer klaren mehrheit gewinnen und der
ganzen nation hinter uns über 74
millionen stimmen aber wir bekommen ich
wiederhole es noch einmal 7 474
millionen nie hat ein präsidentschafts
ticket in der geschichte der usa so
viele stimmen bekommen und es wächst
noch immer weiter wir werden deutschland
um vier millionen stimmen besiegen aber
diese marge nimmt auch noch zu finden
besonders stolz darauf wie wir als erste
demokraten in arizona nach 24 jahren
gewonnen haben
im ersten demokraten die dotter gewinnen
seit 28 jahren
und wir haben die blaue mauer wieder
anderson errichtet das land kribbelte
weg vor ein paar jahren wenn sie wenn
der michigan wisconsin das herzland das
kern land dieser nation
ich weiß dass sie alle finden auch im
fernsehen das geht sehr sehr langsam
villa zahlen kommen langsam aber wir
sollten nicht vergessen es geht hier
nicht nur um zahlen es geht um stimmen
stimmzettel wählerinnen und wähler die
ihr grundrecht ausgeübt haben dass ich
das wichtigste
und gewählt haben es hat sich deutlich
gezeigt dass eine rekordzahl amerikaner
alle rassen alle physiognomie in alle
religionszugehörigkeiten sich für den
wandel entschieden haben gegen das
weiter so ein mandat zu handeln in der
wirtschaft klimawandel chemischen
rassismus haben klargemacht mit ihrem
abstimmverhalten dass sie wollen dass
das land wieder zusammenkommt nicht
weiter auseinander gezerrt wird das volk
und den menschen angesprochen 74
millionen amerikaner laut vernehmbar für
unser ticket jetzt warten wir auf das
schlussergebnis unsere leute wissen aber
dass wir nicht warten dass die arbeit
sich von selber erledigt oder wir warten
nicht ab mit der arbeit sind natur in
harris und ich haben schon gestern mit
sachverständigen zusammen gesessen
eine gesundheitsversorgung in der
wirtschaftskrise der dieses land
entgegen schaut auch die pandemie sie
wissen das wird von tag zu tag und im
ganzen landes schlimmer die täglichen
fälle schießen hoch und wir werden
spitzenwerte bekommt von über 200.000
fälle an einem tag
und denken sie daran wie viele menschen
leben schon verloren sind 240.000 wo
leere plätze sind an den tischen in ganz
amerika in den familien dieses leid
werden die ermessen können diesen
verlust dieses leid dass einige familien
tragen müssen wir wissen wie es ist in
jemanden zu verlieren in der eigenen
familie und ich möchte dass ihr wisst
ihr seid nicht allein
unsere herzen schlagen mit euch und
werden mit euren gebrochen
wir werden vom ersten tag an unseren
plan umsetzen und dieses virus bekämpfen
wir können die verlorenen menschen leben
nicht mehr retten
aber wir können viele menschenleben vor
einem bösen schicksal bewahren in den
nächsten monaten senatorin harris und
ich haben auch gestern über die
wirtschaftslage gesprochen
wir müssen die pandemie unter kontrolle
bekommen 20 millionen menschen sind
schon arbeitslos millionen machen sich
sorgen
wie sie die familie ernähren sollen
schauen sie sich das mal an wir brauchen
einen weg zu einer starken erholen
die erwartungen sind doch dürfen auch
hoch sein
nach schwierigen war noch ein
schwierigen wahlkampf aber vergessen sie
ein dass nicht wir müssen die ruhe
bewahren geduld zeigen den prozess sich
entwickeln lassen indem alle stimmen
ausgezählt werden wir beweisen auch hier
was wir in diesem land die 244 jahren
für wiesn haben die deckungen demokratie
funktioniert die jedes jeder stimmzettel
wird ausgezählt wie energisch man auch
versucht das zu bremsen ich werde das
nicht zulassen
die menschen werden sich mit dem
stimmzettel gehör verschaffen wir sind
für eine stärkere union die sich
weiterentwickeln in amerika haben wir
dezidierte meiner und meinungen sind
auch oft der sehr dezidiert anderer
meinung das ist ja auch in ordnung nur
man muss demokratisch das akzeptieren
dann ist auch ein disput gesund zeichen
für eine lebendige debatte
für feste überzeugungen vergessen wir
eins und die ziel und zweck unserer
politik ist kein krieg ein endloser
totaler krieg sondern zieht sie nutzer
unserer politik der arbeit dieser nation
ist konflikte auszustehen zu lösen
probleme zu überwinden gerechtigkeit zu
gewährleisten damit jeder seine faire
chance bekommt das leben der menschen
verbessern
wir sind vielleicht gegner aber wir sind
keine feinde wir sind amerikaner
egal für wen sie gestimmt hat ich bin
ganz eine sache ganz gewiss die große
mehrheit der 150 millionen
amerikanerinnen und amerikaner die
gewählt haben
die wollen dass der streit verschwindet
aus der politik sie werden in vielen
punkten nicht einer meinung sein aber
gehen wir das durch ritterlich und
höflich an
lassen wir die dämonisierung hinter uns
teilen wir die wunden der nation das
wird nicht leicht sein aber wir werden
alles geben müssen meine verantwortung
als präsident wird es dann die ganze
nation zu viel
treten und ich möchte dass ihr wisst
dass ich für genauso hart für die
arbeitet die gegen mich gestimmt haben
wie die die für mich gehen das ist kern
und inhalt meiner arbeit beauty of care
alle amerikaner zu betreuen und zu
versorgen
wir haben viele probleme corona die
wirtschaft gerechtigkeit ungerechtigkeit
klimawandel wir haben nicht mehr so viel
zeit und in kriegerischen
auseinandersetzung zu verzetteln und
noch viel mehr wir haben eine
einzigartige chance jetzt die zukunft
aufzubauen
für unsere kinder und enkelkinder ich
habe es immer wieder gesagt ich war nie
zuversichtlicher bezüglich der zukunft
dieser nation es gibt auch keinen grund
dass für dieses 21 jahrhundert nicht
gewinnen vergessen wir nicht wer wir
sind die sind die vereinigten staaten
von amerika und es hat nie etwas gegeben
was wir nicht hätten tun können
erreichen können wenn wir versucht dann
gemeinsames zu schaffen
ich danke euch allen wie red morgen
weiter gott segne und schütze euch und
schütze unsere soldaten gute nacht
[Applaus]